il reste maintenant moins d'un mois
avant la date de ces festivités
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation difficile qui nous impose de
faire un choix difficile et cette date
du 2 mai est importante pour l'ensemble
du pays et les préparatifs du défilé
militaire du 9 mai doivent commencer
maintenant
mais sur fond de la crise de l'épidémie
et des risques très importants qui sont
encore existant aujourd'hui ne me
permettent pas de procéder aux
préparatifs des festivités de neuf
humain par conséquent je donne l'ordre
aux structures nouveau force à l'armée
de modifier l'emploi du temps et de
modifier les préparatifs du défilé et de
reporter toutes les festivités publiques
qui était prévue pour le 75e
anniversaire de la victoire